poussés en france le sujet de l'argent
et très tabou et ça n'est rien de le
dire quand il s'agit des sommes
importantes touchés par les footballeurs
qui alimente régulièrement les débats
cette fois ci c'est bfm tv qui a décidé
de piquer au vif les dépenses des stars
du ballon rond en épinglant les joueurs
de l'équipe de france lors de leur
arrivée à clairefontaine au cours d'un
petit sujet fashion week une
chroniqueuse de l'émission de bruce
toussaint s'est amusé à détailler les
prix des vêtements des marques portée
par les bleus presnell kimbembe il
arrive en toute décontraction avec une
petite veste vous le voyez violette
on peut pas le cacher un regard des
traits violette un louis vuitton pour la
modique somme de 1500 1 euro un moment
en plateau qui a particulièrement agacé
les internautes pour beaucoup ce détail
du prix des vêtements des joueurs est
nul et non avenu très vite de nombreux
commentaires ont pris la marque kiabi
comme exemple pour dénoncer l'hypocrisie
des journalistes de la chaîne de
nombreux tweets qui ont même propulsé la
marque qui habille en top tweets france
donc bfm tv fait carrément une chronique
des millionnaires s'habiller avec des
vêtements de luxe plutôt que de se saper
chez kiabi encore plus stupide que le
flou au fc alors selon vous les
footballeurs ont ils raison d'exposer
leurs richesses et regarder oui ici non
là en tout cas il ya deux très fort ici
deux ils vont ils vont ils vont se
défendre alors vous avez vu cette
histoire alors de nombreux internautes
ont défendu les footballeurs suite suite
à cette chronique alors je vous le dis
c'est hier sur bfm tv le jeu la
journaliste est allé sur internet pour
chercher et dévoilé les prix des vestes
des pulls des sacs des chaussures
portées par les joueurs à leur arrivée
regardez ça c'est arrivé ça sent
vraiment de plus en plus à la fashion
week
oui c'est ça chacun avait des joueurs
vous fait vous avez vraiment le bruit de
la caisse enregistreuse
vous prenez par exemple presnell
kimbembe il arrive en toute
décontraction avec une petite veste vous
le voyez louis vuitton pour la modique
somme de 1500 euros tout de même
ensuite on passe à 'aa' guendouzi pour
remplacer matuidi qui s'est blessé alors
forcément est rapidement mis quelque
chose sur son dos ça donne un pull
balanciaga ah bah oui on a pris ce qu'on
avait à 65 euros le reste de ces as de
ses affaires il les a jetés négligemment
dans deux sacs qui se trouvait là de
petits sacs louis vuitton 150 euros
c'est ok avec les
bah oui et puis à aider pour l'accrocher
sur le dos c'est quand même beaucoup
plus sympa juste avant science alors
c'est vrai que voilà donc cette tête
chroniques a fait une énorme polémique
on vous pose la question est un joueur
de foot dont le look fascine plus que
les autres c'est celui d'antoine
griezmann il a carrément un site
internet qui nous dit exactement où
acheter les mêmes fringues que lui les
mêmes fin de compte one regarder quand
on prend par exemple à antoine griezmann
et lui il a carrément un compte
instagram à kiffer les recherches pour
nous c'est à dire vous prenez ce compte
et tout est répertorié vêtements par
vêtements selon les joies et même le
bonnet de son enfant bref y'a tôt sa
petite veste que vous avez vu très chic
basse et de la marque céline à 1990
euros
voilà pour la vaysse la chemise qui a
juste en dessous qui a l'air simple
comme ça 250 euros tout de même temps
même temps il ya un petit truc sur la
poche expliqué que ce soit aussi chez
vous en revanche les baskets des petites
puma blanche simple 100 euros mais ça
progresse même de la collection selena
gomez
ça te salit la tête est un fan de selena
alors voilà c'est avec notre avis bruce
toussaint que j'aime beaucoup aussi en
plus mais c'est vrai que là ça a créé
une énorme polémique cette séquence les
footballeurs ont ils raison d'exposer
leurs richesses et qu'est ce que vous
pensez de cette chronique benhaim mais
sans exposer leurs richesses ils vont
pas et sans exhiber leurs richesses ils
vont pas se cacher de gagner de l'argent
ce serait ridicule et on les pointerait
du doigt si on disait et hypocrites ils
gagnent des millions ils vont pas venir
habillés avec des petites des débuts des
petites marques et on dirait mais qu'est
ce que tu vas tu nous prends pour des
imbéciles
donc voilà on leur demande pas non plus
de d'exhiber mais ils vont pas se cacher
ils n'ont pas volé cet argent
matthieu delormeau alors là n'est pas du
tout d'accord le futur ticker pardon non
mais là il a raison a nommé dans l'es6
et son avis le bateau sera le vainqueur
dans le garros cette année deux millions
et demi d'euros
il en a fait ce qu il en a rien le
football par définition c'est
systématiquement l'indécence c'est quand
l'argent remplace éducation je n'ai
jamais vu un autre sport où c'est un
combat de mma c'est une bagnole à
millions d'euros et je te met des gens
en or et j'arrive avec déchets avaient
et je bouffe de l'avion en avec de l'or
dessus et tout ça c'est le c de la
vulgarité poussé à son comble on peut
gagner de l'argent bien sûr qu'il le
mérite
mais à ce point être aussi indécent le
cracher à la gueule des gens avec ou
sans
et pardon de vous le dire de ce café bfm
au contraire c'est très bien c'est
montrer que ces gens je suis isolé dans
ok y'a des sports organise l armée
encore une fois le tennis de roland
garros les deux millions et demi ça fait
des rondes fois de suite qu'ils le
gagnent ces prix 30 millions d'euros
vous avez déjà vu nadal arrivé comme ça
et claqué son je sais que vous aimez
dernier s'était posée mais des footeux
oui bah moi excusez ma droite sur ce que
vous pensez le trophée de la descente la
plus totale
c'est une honte matthew les doigts de
claquer de l'argent comme ça avec autant
de fierté
maintenant on va voir cinéma et 4.9
maquereau et vous avez droit alors s'il
vous plaît le seul bol ces milieux le
plus populaire mais c'est normal que
quand tu réussis tu viens du plus bas
bien c'est que tu arrives au plus haut
tu es plus enviés d'exposer mais la
façon tu as ta réussite que quand les
pilotes de formule 1 a mené par sujet
milliardaire qui payent la moitié du
budget général en 1001 oulaté videmment
tu peux te la jouer cool façon tu t'es
né avec une cuillère en argent dans la
bouche quand tu viennes bect a réussi
c'est normal temps vide tu es fier de le
montrer
on n'arrive pas à avoir de l'argent ils
ont fait gagner beaucoup ils nous
montrent leur kiffe les vêtements c'est
les jeunes voient la légende s'est dès
lors qu'ils feraient fringues les
marques c'est comme ça alors on va on va
voir ce qu'on pense isabelle est ce
qu'on pensait que des meilleurs systèmes
mathieu va répondre encore les jours des
toutous la réputation d'être bing bling
comme le dit matthieu delormeau ayant
les guignols de l'info avait parodié
leur style de vie à l'époque regarder
quoi plus qu'à toi
hier c'est fait pour nous laurie de
stars chic avec des claquettes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avantage au cpie comme abdellah nos
racines et nous dit la cible quand on se
met à diego au foncier bonne qui serait
beau mais morne et tout à coup on boit
du rinadh en débat à fès puis on se fait
choper par nos épouses
[Applaudissements]
le montant de leur salaire le montant de
leurs transferts le montant de leurs
contrats avec leurs sponsors sont rendus
publics ils sont simplement cohérent
avec ce que l'on sait de leur train de
vie on va pas faire partie de ceux qui
reprochent à des gens de réussir et de
cannes et de la jean laurent cochet
flambée qui flambent qui flambent qu'ils
ne sachent pas s'habiller ils ne savent
pas s'alarmer
qu'est que tu les trouves vulgaire ils
sont vulgaires qu'ils aient pas acheter
le bon pull balanciaga que son permis
avec le bon grands talons chanel c'est
un autre problème ça c'est une question
de style et de goût mais ils ont droit
d'avoir le goût qui est bloquée marans
irin ce qu'ils veulent mais quand c'est
un animateur quand c'est n'importe qui
quand et n'importe quelle autre personne
même quand ça bernard arnault ou
quelqu'un qui fait vivre ou même bolloré
qui paie ses impôts en france et qui
fait vivre 50000 personnes
quand une acura salaires par il en prend
plein la gueule mais comme c'est un
footballeur parce qu'il a mis un but
pour la france ou de tout pardonner
voiture que j'avais vu acheté je sais
plus si c'était un ribéry pardon si
c'est pas lui c'est était endiguée
mais oui c'est votre ami building des
parisiens aujourd'hui c'est drucker et
benzema tout le monde tu es benzema
n'était pas réellement harris et une
butée d'humberto c'est un million cent
mille heureux et je te l'a montré elle
en aurait tout ça qu'il fasse mais il
fait rêver les jeunes rêvent énergique
cyril il ya un truc que vous devez
comprendre faire rêver les jeunes il
faut comprendre qu encore une fois faire
rêver les jeunes c'est pas être gavé de
fric et l'exposer en permanence c'est
être un petit peu éduqués faire un
métier qu'on aime c'est pour vous a
permis g fabien a toisé d'union le maire
je pense que mathieu fauves retourner le
problème parce qu'en fait je dois partir
je veux bien non c'est à dire que c'est
ce que ce qu'on faut comprendre c'est le
public est demandeur de sartre et ça
c'est pas les footeux qui provoquent ils
font que répondre à la demande d'un
public les publics m saint nazaire
blessé le film et le public aime ça le
public rachète les mêmes vêtements que
parce que c'est une demande du public et
les marques utilisent d'ailleurs les
footballeurs comme toutes les stars de
cinéma dans les vraies demandes du
public c'est important de le rappeler ça
et je laisse parler il nous après
simplement eric naulleau seul vrai
scandale vestimentaires que j'ai vu dans
le football c'est quand ribéry a
débarqué en claquettes au milieu en une
émission de télévision là il y avait
vraiment un scandale embarrassant
gérer quelque chose dans des galets oui
moi je n'ai pas beaucoup fréquenté les
footballeurs mais je vois que sont très
copains même avec les rappeurs par
exemple et ils ont un peu tendance à
adopter le même mode de l'art est nommé
olivier chocat qui est un pote sur agent
olivier il est trés litres discovery est
très discret il a griezmann filet très
discret il est très discret je suis allé
chez lui un austère il est très discret
april a un bon look voilà c'est tout
c'est voilà cyril qui domine et mathieu
c'est une séance bénagues et
d'inégalités sociales c'est comme ça
c'est pas autrement c'est malheureux
mais ça existe et semsales le monde ne
tournerait pas rond peut pas tous être
riche tout cette pauvre et ça faut
l'accepter malheureusement en
l'occurrence là les journalistes ce
qu'ils ont fait c'est qu'ils ont décrit
comment était habillé les footballeurs
mais ce que les footballeurs se sont
montrés et ont montré sur les deux
surnoms ne sont pas mis la marque ils
ont pas toutes à gué ils sont pas il
s'habille comme ça c'est chéreau quoi
ces légendes jusque là en train de vous
lui montrez belge indépendant et je
défende pas de s'il l'achète bons fous
sur mon banc de touche est sûr c'est que
ce qu'est ce qu'ils ont voulu montrer
c'est que pour vous dans ce que vous
dites avoir de l'argent c'est réussi à
ces passages de réussir mon avis c'est
un rendez vous que les enfants cyril
vous avez tout à l'heure vous avez tout
à l'heure bah c'est normal ils font
rêver rêver les enfants
mais c'est un pas des sommes pour vous
pour les enfants n'empêche
qu'aujourd'hui j'ai envie d'être comme
eux je vais réussir peut-être toile à
réussir cet aprem à mon argent si reed
réussir c'est se réaliser soi même
matière
j'ai toujours su apprendre à mamie non
ce que je sais c'est que nous voulons
c'est que les journalistes ne font
qu'attiser la haine des gens c'est un
genre de reportage parce que sans ça je
ne se poserait pas sur la grève il n'y a
pas le cas ribéry mangé un steak au nord
et qu'une fois sur un sacre à tokyo ont
là ça justement et franck ribéry il fait
ce qu'il veut et puis désole t il le
monde parce que voilà il voulait laisser
les policiers arriver si vous regardez
un resto c'est 1200 euros la pièce de
boeuf
voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
là que tu nous entends mais non non mais
dans la vidéo il a pas d'âme aux
technophiles 200 euros on le sait mais
pas du tout non c'était marrant la la
vidéo avec le maillot et on l'a prise
pour lui il est au menu du restaurant
c'est à ça que je tiens au fait isabelle
morini-bosc je suis plus le foot devrait
plaire de le dire voyez par exemple
relativement et pathé par la carrière de
ribéry qui s'est assagi qui a fait une
bonne carrière
giroux et loris je l'aimé à part
maintenant je comprends ce que veut dire
oui je comprends ce que veut dire tu
sais le battle mathieu parce que
effectivement moi qui fait qu'ils aient
de l'argent et qu'ils achètent faut
faire marcher le commerce il faut bien
que les gens qui achètent des choses les
très riches pour les très riches en
revanche qui m'embête c'est que ça sent
que cela s'accompagne d'un comportement
souvent bling-bling machin est sous
relativement souvent immatures et sa
conjointe de sortie à des moments
improbables et c'est bien de même que la
valeur que ce n'est pas tant l'argent
des femmes fonctionnement ainsi que
quand tu n'as pas d'argent tu n'as pas
réussi a été merveilleuse n'est jamais
juste voir mois cyril ce qu'ont réussi
s'cusez moi quand tu réussis c'est quand
même équipe de se faire plaisir première
et une deuxième chose c'est bon mais là
depuis l'âge de 8 ans ils sont enfermés
ils font du foot ils font du sport
ils sont enfin un peu libre de ce qu'ils
peuvent avec leurs avants qu'est ce que
tu leur reproche de le montrer mais on
les pointe du doigt si tu cites et
céréales à l'arrivée des tennismans à
roland garros tu devrais leur bagnole
mais bon on ne filme pas c'est ballot
les finish côté de la rançon et film
c'est pour ça qu'on peut pas reprocher
ça surtout toi
et montré les images de sa maison à
madrid regardez la maison de cristiano à
gaza lui l'ia entre et c'est là où je
vis ma chambre est l'une des choses les
plus importantes de même ici c'est là où
je dors est ce que vous savez c'est
important de se tenir en forme et haut
niveau le salon où je regarde la télé
les matches ici c'est l'endroit où je ne
reproche courir avec mes amis et ici
c'est l'endroit où je joue au foot veut
pas on à laquelle je faute juste ici
lehnert willi haag à mathieu pour te
faire plaisir ou pour ne pas de
t'énerver il aurait fallu qu'ils
arrivent à billets en haillons ou en
simplement arrivé au rassemblement de la
sélection parce qu'ils ont un mac ils
sont arrivés comme il était habillé
point barre ya pas de débat et ce
reportage sur bfm c'est largement
retourner contre eux parce que toute la
journée surtout c'est vrai il ya eu le
hashtag qui habitait blé en top tweets
parce que tout le monde tout le monde a
eu la même réflexion mais vous voulez
quoi en fait qui s'habillent qui
s'habiller avec des vêtements à 2 euros
à tout tout est dans tout et a dit ce
qu'il est contre moi j'avais plein de
gens excuse n'est pas très sobre non un
décalage total entre les commentaires et
même ce que ni mathieu est ce qu'on a vu
à l'écran j'ai pas vu des choses
scandalisés mais là sur cinquante mille
hausses de prix c'est un des sommets
eric levrat plus que cette chronique
sinon débat n'a aucun intérêt c'est pas
pour savoir si samedi en kabylie où
invitons à idc c'est bien ce que ça veut
dire ce qu'on veut dire c'est que le
football malheureusement est le sport
qui les ont voulu faire à museler le ton
du conte de bling bling qui laisse
entendre pour réussir commence ay à ce
sport qu'il adore le plus d'argent
pas bien ça merde dans une époque
d'image et c'est vraiment notre époque
aujourd'hui on a besoin de modèles et
les et les footballeurs des stars on a
bossé modèle gens dont on a besoin de
gens qui représentent des modèles et une
société pour que les gens c'est une
demande du public pour bien comprendre
cette faut retourner la situation c'est
pas du tout
il y avait une vidéo qui avait fait un
petit peu polémique aussi c'est après
avoir ramené la coupe du monde à la
maison certains joueurs de l'équipe de
france ont fêté leur victoire à miami
voilà ils ont fait un qui fait
exactement comme tout le monde aurait
fait voilà comment je gagne dans le
garage et une fête à miami ou si vous
voulez venir
non non
[Musique]
est ce m
déjà
alors oui alesi qu'ils aient réussi qu
ils méritent leur argent oui qu'ils
aient réussi puisque ce soient des stars
oui qu'ils soient très bien p parce
qu'ils rapportent autant
oui c'est bien mais encore une fois ce
qui est mon problème à moi c'est qui
fait qu'ils fassent ce qu'ils veulent
qu'ils ne dépensent que me veulent mais
cette idée de vouloir le montre en
permanence alors que les gens alors et
je fais pas le truc mais effectivement
que je passe parfois des très beaux vins
de pinot et que j'aimerai voiture est ce
que tu me vois dans une belle voiture il
est illégal
les gens qui sont en face de shoushi
regarder qui eux n'ont rien compris
demandé à petit 2 je suis désolé je suis
un autre cyrille l'exemple qu'on doit
donner quand tu viens de dire que les
modèles les modèles aujourd'hui en
images sont des footballeurs mais tu
plaisantes ou bien des malades à des
histoires de 2,2 par les mairies au sexe
ni de dire des bêtises
oui à 68% alors à 32% il serait plutôt
de votre côté